it's in some sense a closed system where
cause and effect works according to
their own little rules
[Music]
is the metaverse an inevitable future or
is it a sci-fi fantasy and marketing
device and I'd like to start with you
Anders and my answer is of course yes
so before I ended up in the philosophy
Department I was a computer scientist
and instead of doing the neural network
research I was supposed to be doing in
the 90s I was actually doing a fair bit
of virtual reality back when you needed
a Mainframe silicon Graphics computer
that was pretty expensive and you had a
really bulky headset and nothing really
worked and it was extremely jerky and we
were of course imagine we were creating
the future
because that first peak of thinking
about virtual reality in the 90s there
was an explosion of visions that very
much is similar to today this is going
to change everything the future is
virtual you had movies like lawnmower
man that was kind of blowing up this
idea
and that was partially because of
fiction a bit earlier the cyberpunk
fiction created the cause of virtual
reality including Neil Stevenson's
amazing novel snow crash where he
describes a splintered future where
there is something called the metaverse
that a lot of people log into and is the
really powerful force in this story this
is where you meet this is where you
interact that novel had a device called
Earth which was run by the privatized
CIA and that allows you to zoom in on
any place on Earth and get the
information that inspired Google Earth a
lot the of work on virtuality got
inspired by this very well informed
novel which of course points out that
whoever owns the platform the metaverse
has tremendous amount of power now it
missed the fact that controlling the
discourse on the platform is how you get
the real power he was kind of more
imagining that the power came from a
physical platform but it made a good
point and it's kind of hilarious that
methanol talks about the metaverse
because it's based on a novel
criticizing big corporations which shows
that nobody ever learns anything and to
conclude when I tried out a modern
virtual reality a while ago whoa It's so
smooth and it runs on a mere good gaming
computer rather than a Mainframe
computer but we're still not very good
at making it look organic because
modeling is hard creating procedural
texture is hard we still do really don't
know what to do with it yet just like we
didn't know what to do with it in the
night this so I think we're totally
going to be tinkering with this and
trying to find that killer application
that makes his work but but it's going
to take time and nobody really knows
where it's going but certainly people
are going to try to control that
platform
great thank you Massimo
uh Beware of anybody who tells you that
they're going to change everything
because then they're going to do it and
you're not going to have a voice in it
so one of the people that is telling you
this kind of stuff is Nick cleck who is
president of global Affairs at meta
and I'm going to give you a couple of
quotes that might stimulate discussion
around from an article that he just
published last week
he says companies like meta have a lot
of work to do both to build the
credibility of the metaverse as an idea
and to demonstrate to people that we are
committed to building it a responsible
way it means being open and transparent
about the work we're doing and the
choices and trade-offs inherent in it it
means drawing on existing work on work
to protect marginalized communities
online and listening to human and civil
rights privacy and disabilities experts
as systems and processes are developed
to keep people safe
sounds to me like somebody's on the
defensive here you know you keep telling
you that oh don't worry this time we're
gonna get it right the last time that
they got it wrong was last year so it's
not exactly a great track record
um he goes on and says technology isn't
good or bad in and of itself
I don't think so my friend technology is
built in a certain way and this notion
that technology is actually neutral that
it's all up to us how do we use it or
not is actually dangerous yeah there are
some technologies that are meant to do
certain things rather than others for
instance at home I have a nice hammer
it's meant to hammer stuff into the wall
I could also use it to crush somebody's
skull and that would definitely be a bad
use of that technology it's not meant to
do that sort of stuff the question is
what is meant what is this stuff meant
to do and I suspected that it's closer
to the crush sculling thing than to the
uh hanging Nails on the wall so if you
believe all of that you know he goes on
and says one more word it needs to be
developed that the platform openly with
a spirit of cooperation between the
private sector lawmakers the Civil
Society Academia and the people who will
use these Technologies this effort must
be undertaken in the best interest of
people in society not just technology
companies if you believe that I have a
nice bridge in Brooklyn that I can tell
you for real
they're gonna hear your thoughts about
this yeah so
uh as you said I tend to be a technic
pessimist uh but really what I wanted to
talk about for my pitch today was VR as
a mirror to where we are anyway without
VR because I really think the metaverse
is an expression of some existing
civilizational trends that we don't pay
enough attention to so really it's
useful to think about VR to really think
about where we're at anyway so a really
obvious point about virtual reality is
that there's a lack of connection
between sensory experiences and bodily
consequences so you can imagine in a VR
you can be in the simulation where
you're running along a Clifford or
you're in a shootout and you could be
really terrified
um and you've got all of the visual and
auditory sensations of these experiences
but there's no actual bodily threats
um and philosophers like to imagine you
know future VR where not just sound and
um and vision and touch are simulated
but all of the five senses including you
know sound and taste and smell so you
can imagine eating virtual food so you
could have a Lobster Thermidor some
really luxurious food that you wouldn't
be able to afford in real life but it
would be completely without nourishment
to actually you know get food to survive
you'd have to leave the metaverse and
take real food or you'd have to be in
the metaverse with some feeding tube
wired up to you but there's this
disconnect between the sensory
experiences and the actual consequences
for your body so the Lobster Thermidor
in this VR it won't nourish you but it
also can't give you food poisoning right
so good and bad with this but why do I
think that's the crystallization of um
existing Trends because this seems like
a really like like a Sci-Fi scenario but
if you think about plenty of our
technologies that we have today already
that we're completely used to they're
all already doing that thing of like
breaking the connection between the
sensory experiences we're getting and
the body so if you think about
widespread availability of contraception
what that did is break the automatic
connection between sex and the
possibility of pregnancy that was there
you know before this technology was
widely available
um if you think about food handling
technologies that you have today it kind
of breaks the connection between needing
to really taste your food to check that
it's safe to eat and just you know food
as this nice sensory experience
because you just for any food that you
buy in a supermarket within its best
before date you assume that it's not
going to give you food poisoning you
don't really need to use your senses to
check the bodily consequences of what's
going on
um
so I think we should be aware of you
know a conception of Technology it's
useful to think about technology in
general as things that you know
create a medium or a means between your
goals as a human being and some like
um some something in nature that you're
directed to think of social media it's a
technological platform in between you
and the people that you want to interact
with so Technologies in general have
this mediating
characteristic and The Meta verses like
this extreme version of that is creating
this big sort of sensory
buffer around us but without connection
to the you know actual forces in nature
that Keep Us Alive Etc Keep Us Alive but
would also be threatening to us thank
you
um I will I will you'll get the chance
to say more about that actually
um but I'd like to start with our first
theme now and like think about the
philosophical question around this
debate because we're talking about
reality and virtual reality but what
what is the difference between the two
how can we even distinguish between
reality and virtual reality and I'd like
actually to start with humans okay yeah
so so thinking about this this is um
is it connects with what I was saying
before because
um you know what is reality that's a
huge philosophical question one handy
way of thinking about reality that's um
makes sense in this context not the only
way but is reality is whatever pushes
back against your agency so if you think
about a brick wall imagine that's a
brick wall not just a flimsy fabric wall
there's a real brick wall I wouldn't be
able to just walk through it if I wanted
to if it was a hallucinated brick wall I
could just walk through it so reality is
gonna you know confront me with its own
agency pushing back so I think what's
really interesting about the metaverse I
don't think it's you know
it is a re you we can argue that it's a
reality because it's running in real
computers and there's real you know
digital objects there but what's
distinctive about it as a reality is
that there isn't non-human agency in the
fabric of it so the other agents that
will be in the metaverse will be other
human beings and the digital objects
will be the creations of algorithms
programmed by human beings the
algorithms could have emergent
properties which would sort of be
unpredictable by the human programmers
but what will be missing there is
um agency from non-human actors such as
animals microbes a tree that might fall
fall on you a lightning strike that
might that might hit you so it's a very
different kind of reality in that sense
it's sort of closing off the non-human
agency which we might think that the
already this process of technological
mediation has already built a big wall
around us from the rest of
um nature yeah and this what do you
think about that do you think that
resistance and unpredictability are good
ways to Define reality versus virtual
reality
I'm not certain if they would be good
ways of defining it but I think there
are an important component so I'm rather
fond of David Chalmers take on virtual
reality he's been cornering the market
of philosopher materiality ever since he
wrote about Matrix and the philosophy
and he makes this argument that we
should actually treat Virtual Worlds as
real in the sense that virtual objects
have causal Powers if I use my virtual
sword on the virtual Dragon I might be
able to kill it the virtual Dragon might
threat to my virtual Avatar there are
interactions going on in this little
environment it's in some sense a closed
system where cause and effect works
according to their own little rules and
as he points out this means that
experience is in there matter but but
the interesting part is of course it's
this immersive interactive thing but
it's also run on a computer now some
realities around on other realities I'm
kind of willing to have multi the layers
and realities and some realities are
very simple like a chess game it's its
own little self-contained reality that
has this weird rule that entities from
outside that reality move pieces around
but virtual reality thing is running on
a server somewhere and if somebody pulls
out the plug that dragon and my sword
and my avatar disappears into
nothingness the interesting thing is
that some of these systems are dependent
on each other and that gives a
tremendous amount of power now it's true
that most virtual reality environments
we make today are really boring because
people have put everything in there even
the trees or standard algorithmic clip
art trees right now I love artificial
life I actually like making environments
that evolve on their own where there is
agency of some virtual form going on
among the organisms that you get
emergent properties that I didn't put in
there but entities learn and do things
and I might discover hilarious and the
interesting new things we're not doing
enough of that and I'm wishing that we
will be doing more of that in the future
because otherwise it's going to be
pretty sterile but it's kind of hard to
decide when you make a virtual reality
if you're not really good at programming
really great at creating artificial life
and a great graphical designer you're
probably going to use that standard
Square clipboard table and the standard
the table textures there is a risk that
we're having a hard time creating the
complexity that truly matters and that I
think is a real problem and we need to
work against it but it's partial a
design problem rather than a political
problem or a technological problem and
from a philosophical standpoint I think
we need this pushback I really love that
point otherwise getting everything you
want at the naive way means that you get
bored so you mean there's a way to build
the unpredictability into the technology
and that that would be a way to like not
be able to distinguish between the two
Massimo thoughts are optimistic like
Anders or pessimistic about that I like
to be realistic about things so David
Chalmers Who full disclosure I think is
actually being wrong on pretty much
everything in his life
um
just to put things out there
has a very interesting
conception of causality as you pointed
out the difference between
my virtual dragon and a real dragon
coming into this room is I if I'm afraid
of the virtual Dragon I can just turn
off my computer and the Virtual Drive
and it's gone the real one is gonna eat
me no matter what uh and there's nothing
I can I can turn off Philip K dick who
was a famously dystopian brilliant
science fiction uh author said that
reality is the thing that doesn't go
away when you stop believing in it right
and that is the part of the problem one
of one of the points that was made a few
minutes ago was that there has to be
consequences
for for something to be called a reality
if I eat the lobster and I don't get
either the food poisoning or the
nourishment I'm not actually eating the
lobster I'm only engaging in something
that looks from the outside as eating a
lot of lobster so the part of the
question here is do we want that kind of
non-reality
it's we can call it virtual reality but
I think it's a more appropriate term is
non-reality uh in a sense it's a fantasy
world that we can build uh to some
extent to our own content to much more
of an extent to the contentment of
Zuckerberg and mosque and people like
that uh and then so the basic question
is do we want that kind of non-reality
do we want what kind of role do we want
that non-reality to play I mean we all I
don't know about all but many of us
personally what we have in fact
interacted with virtual platforms like
you play a video game and it can be fun
for a few minutes or for half an hour
for an hour if it gets to occupied 12
hours a day of my life then I think it's
uh getting getting to the point of uh so
psychological pathology and not not
something that I want so but you're
basically saying that unpredictability
cannot really be built into the
technology because of the body not
really taking part as like and Savita
was saying I would say that
unpredictability can definitely be built
it's credibility that cannot be built
right because ultimately so long as I am
in control of using the virtual reality
interface I know that I can't get out of
it no consequence and there's thoughts
about that and then yeah well I think
there are consequences because quite a
lot of interaction we do in Virtual
Reality might have persistent effects
not just in the sense that maybe when
you turn on the computer the dragon is
in the back there and programmed to be
even more angry but a lot of interaction
we do in Virtual Reality or social if I
yell at somebody in an online Forum
there are actual consequences now you
might say yeah but that's because we're
real people behind the the scenes here
you get really upset but I think the
virtual reality we call the universities
just like that the university is a place
where people come together and role play
this we are the activity we have a
various names and ideas about what's
going on we're very happen to be very
physically but we're playing a kind of
elaborate social game according to
particular social rules and many of them
matter quite a lot for the rewards we
get in terms of payment and or
credibility to getting invited wonderful
festivals things like that
so I do think that actually that when
the lobster fermudor is not real that
mostly matters if you care about the
nourishment part but if you say eating a
lobster thermador is a social occasion I
want to have a nice Lobster with my
friends even over this route of many
continents that aspect of a nice dinner
is relevant to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas